so all the very heavy elements like this
one rutherfordium have only been ever
been made in very small quantities
usually by using a high voltage
accelerator to accelerate atoms of some
lighter elements and banging them into a
heavy target of something like uranium
and the very few atoms of these elements
are formed it's rather like having a
large bubble and banging a smaller
babble into it and suddenly you make a
really wobbly bubble really big one
which may suddenly break apart and
rather for diem is named after Ernest
Rutherford who was a New Zealander who
worked in Canada and then worked in
Manchester and finally in Cambridge and
he was quite well enormously famous
scientist he had 11 of his doctoral
students became Nobel Prize winners in
their own right and he is still
remembered by the so-called Rutherford
lectures which are given in in in New
Zealand Australia and in Canada and
lastly I was fortunate enough to be the
Rutherford lecturer in Canada and there
is a rumor in my wife's family there
nobody's quite sure what the connection
is that my wife's grandfather who was a
physicist had some connection to with
Rutherford but we've never been able to
find out what it is Rutherford was well
known to believe that his students
shouldn't work too long hours and he
insisted that his lab in Cambridge was
closed at six o'clock and everybody
should go home and they still won eleven
Nobel Prizes